[Music]
welcome
our couples are ready to roll the dice
on our first ever biggest night
competition what happens in Vegas
apparently stays on the ballroom floor
Heather Morris scored the first nine of
the Dancing with the Stars season for
her sultry tango with fillin partner
Alan Burstyn the duo nabbed a 33 out of
40 but the real victory getting a
positive health update from Maksim
Chmerkovskiy who sat out after suffering
a calf injury last week I'm hoping for
like a fool comeback end of this week
and then we'll start rehearsing Sharna
Burgess and Bonner Bolton brought 1920s
Flair with their Charleston but didn't
seem to impress the judges earning a 24
out of 40 a drop from last week's score
of 29 out of 40 when we got up stage the
first thing I said to bono was I love
that you're bummed but I'm frustrated
that you're bummed I want him to
acknowledge the difficulty of that
routine with the injuries that we've had
to have the coordination to do a
Charleston is I mean it's so intense and
I feel like he did a fantastic job
the evening was over-the-top and full of
energy but there was one number that got
us a bit emotional
here's Julianne and Derek Hough
performing a routine from there move
beyond tour inspired by their parents
divorce
unfortunately by the end of the night
the lights dimmed for one of these Vegas
acts the couple leaving right now is
Charo and Kido Bruno I'll see you the
parking lot okay what happens if you see
Bruno in the parking lot what's gonna
happen he will tell you will read in the
paper crime pays
[Music]
you